michel dauphinais nous écrit pour savoir
est ce que c'est vrai que dans le
programme de la cac
si le parti forme le prochain
gouvernement on permettrait
l'exploration et l'exploitation du
pétrole et du gaz de schiste dans des
zones moins densément peuplées c'est
effectivement ce que prévoit le
programme de la caq de le permettre dans
des zones qui ne sont pas densément
peuplées mais aussi là où il y as
acceptabilité sociale et le chef
françois legault donné en exemple l'île
d'anticosti
du côté du parti libéral philippe
couillard a déjà annoncé qu'il allait
mettre un terme définitif à
l'exploitation du gaz de schiste par
fracturation légalement indiqué qu'il
était contre tous nouveaux projets
d'hydrocarbures par exemple sur l'île
d'anticosti
au parti québécois on tient la même
position on assure qu'aucun nouveau
projet d'hydrocarbures ne sera autorisé
québec solidaire enfin veut mettre fin à
toute recherche toute mise en
exploitation des énergies fossiles
si vous avez des questions sur cette
élection québécoise on a des réponses
laissez nous vos commentaires écrivez
nous vos élections à ta radio tirer
canada.ca